TIME SADLY BUT I KNOW WE
WILL MEET AGAIN.
JORGE, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: WELL, DURING
TODAY'S TELEVISED
HOW THE FINAL DACA DEAL WILL
THOSE ON THIS CHANNEL.
>> I'M LINDSEY AMNESTY OR
LINDSEY GOMEZ EVERY NAME HAS
BEEN ASSIGNED TO ME.
I'M STILL STANDS.
THE PEOPLE OF SOUTH CAROLINA
WANT A RESULT.
HOW COULD I BE ELECTED?
I HAVE BEEN FOR A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR 11 MILLION
PEOPLE.
I HAVE NO AM NECESSARY MOSS
HOMBRES I WANT MERIT BASED
WE MADE A DECISION NOT TO DO
IT COMPREHENSIVELY.
I THINK THAT'S A SMART
COMPREHENSIVE BILLS OUT OF
THE SENATE WITH OVER 65
VOTES THAT GO TO THE HOUSE
AND DIE AND I'M NOT BEING
DISPARAGING TO MY HOUSE
COLLEAGUES THIS IS STUFF
POLITIC FUSS ARE A
REPUBLICAN HOUSE MEMBER
TURNING ON THE RADIO.
TO MY DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS,
THANKS FOR COMING, THE
RESIST MOVEMENT HATES THIS
GUY.
THEY DON'T WANT HIM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AT ALL.
YOU TURN ON FOX NEWS AND CAN
I HEAR THE DRUM BEAT COMING.
RIGHT WING RADIO AND TV TALK
SHOW HOSTS ARE GOING TO BEAT
THE CRAP OUT OF US BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO BE AMNESTY ALL
OVER AGAIN.
>> Tucker: SENATOR GRAHAM
INSTANTLY, INSTANTLY TURNED
DOWN OUR REQUEST TO COME ON
TONIGHT AND EXPLAIN HIMSELF.
SO DID VIRTUALLY EVERY
ILLINOIS SAID YES AND WE ARE
GRATEFUL THAT HE DID.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SO I UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERN ABOUT DACA
RECIPIENTS, SOME OF WHOM,
YOU KNOW, DIDN'T CHOOSE TO
COME HERE AND THEY'RE STUCK
HERE AND IT'S A STICKY
SITUATION, I GET IT.
BUT IF YOU ARE CREATING A
HIERARCHY OF CONCERNS WHY IS
THIS A MORE PRESSING MATTER
THAN SAY THE OPIOID CRISIS
OR THE RISE IN HEALTHCARE
>> WELL, THANK YOU, TUCKER.
I ACTUALLY THINK THOSE
ISSUES ARE SOMEWHAT RIGHTED.
TO GET A DACA FIX.
WE WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PRESIDENT CONTINUES TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW
LEADERSHIP LIKE HE HAS ON
SUCH A VERY DIFFICULT ISSUE.
AND WE CAN ALSO IMPLEMENT
SOME REPUBLICAN IMMIGRATION
REFORMS.
BORDER SECURITY MEASURES.
YOU MENTIONED THE OPIOID
CRISIS.
YOU TALK TO ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL IN MY
DISTRICT IN CENTRAL ILLINOIS
THEY WILL TELL YOU THE
SCOURGE OF HEROIN AND ICE
COMING THROUGH OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER WE NEED SOME PHYSICAL
DECIDE WHERE THEY GO.
>> Tucker: FOR SURE.
THAT SOUNDS SENSIBLE.
BUT THE CORE OF THIS, THE
CENTERPIECE, THE DEBATE
RERECIPIENTS.
HOW DOES THAT HELP YOUR
CITIZENS?
>> FIRST OFF, LET'S TAKE A
STEP BACK.
LET SEEMS WHAT COMES OF THIS
MEETING.
OBVIOUSLY, AGAIN, I THOUGHT
THE PRESIDENT SHOWED GREAT
LEADERSHIP AND A VERY
DIFFICULT ISSUE THAT HE IS
WILLING TO TAKE A STAND ON.
LET'S ACTUALLY SEE WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE LOOKS
LIKE.
LET'S SEE IF THERE IS ANY
BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, LET'S
TRIAL AND SOLVE A PROBLEM
THAT THE PRESIDENT ASKED US
TO SOLVE WHEN HE GOT RID OF
AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL
EXECUTIVE ACTION.
>> Tucker: I GET IT TOUGH
PLACE TRAP LAID BY THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION AND
REPUBLICANS, OF COURSE,
WALKED RIGHT INTO IT IF YOU
TAKE THREE STEPS BACK IT
SOUNDS WEIRD THAT WE'RE WITH
TO SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT
OVER LEGALIZING ILLEGAL
ALIENS WHEN 6 MILLION DIED
OF DRUG ODS AND NO
AFFORDABLE COLLEGE 5R7BD BAD
THINGS.
CONCERN OF ILLEGAL ALIENS
PUT TOP TOP OF THE LIST.
CAN YOU SEE WHY BEWILDERED
BY.
THIS ONLY ONES TALKING ABOUT
SHUTTING DOWN THE GOVERNMENT
IS THE DEMOCRATS.
THE REPUBLICANS WANT COMMON
SENSE SOLUTION THAT INCLUDES
BORDER SECURITY MEASURES.
NEVER THE ONES THAT WANT TO
SEE THIS LINK TO A
GOVERNMENT SHUT DOWN.
TODAY.
LET'S SEE WHAT THE END
RESULTS ARE.
LET'S SEE IF SENATOR DURBIN
AND THE REST OF THE
DEMOCRATS COME OUT AFTER
THIS MEETING AND STILL WANT
TO NEGOTIATE A BORDER
SECURITY MEASURE THAT
INCLUDES SOME PHYSICAL
STRUCTURES?
LET'S SEE WHAT COMES OF THIS
MEETING BEFORE WE EVEN SEE
THE LEGISLATION THAT COMES
OUT AND SEE THE END RESULT
OF THAT.
>> Tucker: BUT IF
REPUBLICANS ACCEPT A DEAL
THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE
AND THE DIVERSITY LOTTERY
AND BUILD A WALL, WHY WOULD
ANYBODY EVER VOTE REPUBLICAN
AGAIN?
HONESTLY?
>> WELL, I THINK, AGAIN,
THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY, IF
YOU HAVE IDEAS, THAT ARE
REPUBLICAN IMMIGRATION
REFORMS, THE PRESIDENT
CLEARLY SAID NOW'S THE TIME
TO PUT THOSE IDEAS ON THE
TABLE.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT IN
OUR CONFERENCE FOR YEARS.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, YOU
DOESN'T EVEN COME THROUGH
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT COMES THROUGH OUR
VISAS HERE ILLEGALLY AND WE
DON'T HAVE ANY BIOMETRIC
CAPABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
TRACK THEM AND FIGURE OUT
WHERE THEY HAVE GONE.
>> Tucker: WOULD YOU SUPPORT
A DEAL THAT DOESN'T END
CHAIN MIGRATION FOR DACA
RECIPIENTS?
>> AGAIN, LET'S SEE WHAT THE
BILL LOOKS LIKE BECAUSE I
THINK THESE ARE SOME OF THE
PRIORITIES THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS CLEARLY LAID
OUT IN THE PAST AND I
BELIEVE WILL CLEARLY LAY OUT
WITH REPUBLICAN SUPPORT AS
WE LOOK AHEAD TO THE NEXT
FEW DAYS.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
THIS IS MAKING ME NERVOUS.